problema número 173 la probabilidad de
que una moneda caiga en cierta cara en
un lanzamiento dado es de un medio si la
moneda va a lanzarse tres veces cuál es
la probabilidad de que la moneda caiga
en cara cuando menos una vez lo que nos
piden es la probabilidad de que caiga al
menos al menos una vez
en cara
pensemos en el caso opuesto esto es
equivalente a decir cuál es la
probabilidad
la probabilidad de no tener
todas
en cruz
es lo mismo estas no son equivalentes y
esta es igual a 1 - p de tener todos
cruz
es todos
cruz es decir que caiga la moneda en
cruz todas las veces y obtener esta
probabilidad no es difícil para nada
esto es igual a tener un medio por un
medio ya que la vamos a lanzar tres
veces por un medio
y esto es igual a un octavo
todo esto es uno menos un octavo
qué es lo mismo que tener un entero ocho
octavos menos un octavo nos quedan siete
octavos
es la opción de cuando tenemos estos
problemas de obtener la probabilidad de
al menos una cosa si lo tratamos de
resolver tal cual pues va a ser un poco
difícil pero si pensamos en el problema
puesto y luego lo arrestamos a uno pues
va a ser algo mucho más sencillo
siguiente problema problema número 174
las calificaciones finales recibidas por
los estudiantes de un curso de
matemáticas 1 5º tienen a un cuarto
tienen vez un medio tienen zen y las
diez calificaciones restantes tienen de
puedes la cantidad de alumnos en el
curso veamos cuál es la fracción de las
veces los que reprobaron y veamos cuáles
son las fracciones de las otras
calificaciones los datos que nos dan es
un quinto de a
un cuarto que tiene más la mitad que
tuvieron ce y de estos vamos a encontrar
el común denominador que es 2020 5 por 4
20 4 por 14 más 5 por 4 25 por 15 más 10
por 2 2010 por 110 sumamos a esto y nos
da 19 veinteavos de la clase y nos dicen
que las 10 calificaciones restantes son
de para que esto sea un entero nos falta
un veinteavo entonces este 20 algo que
falta son las 10 calificaciones
si una veinteava parte de la clase es
igual a 10 que sacaron d
entonces seguramente a la parte de la
clase
es 10 alumnos y si despejamos se se va a
ser igual a 10 por 20 200 nuestra clase
va a ser de 200 alumnos
es nuestra opción de siguiente problema
a más de 175 conforme x se incrementa de
175 a 166 cuál de los siguientes también
se incrementa tenemos estas opciones 2 x
menos 5 bueno si x aumenta eso está
multiplicado por dos
aunque le restamos un 5 está todo esto
va a aumentar entonces éste se
incrementa
1 - 1 / x esto de aquí va al aumentar
esta fracción va a ser que sea más
chiquita si tenemos uno entre 165 esto
va a ser mayor a 1 entre 166 pero como
estamos restando esta fracción esto en
total va a aumentar casi que éste
también se incrementa
vemos 1 entre x al cuadrado menos x
bueno esta parte de aquí si ustedes
recuerdan sus clases de cálculo sabrán
que esto es una parábola que va a estar
más o menos así y esta parte se va a
incrementar justo a esta parte de acá
pero como esta es una fracción esta
parte de acá al aumentar la fracción se
va a ser más pequeña así que todo esto
no se incrementa cuando se incrementa la
x
nuestras opciones son 1 y 2 que si se
incrementan y esta es a su vez la opción
c esta es nuestra respuesta correcta
siguiente problema problema número 176
tenemos esta cajita y la pregunta es
cuál es la distancia más grande en
centímetros que pueda haber entre dos
puntos de esta caja
bueno la distancia más grande es una
diagonal tridimensional que iría más o
menos de este punto de acá
atravesando el volumen de la caja y
llegando a esta esquina superior y si
saben cómo calcular las distancias en
tres dimensiones pues es todo lo que van
a necesitar para calcular esta distancia
y vamos a necesitar encontrar la raíz
cuadrada de 10 al cuadrado más 5 al
cuadrado más 10 al cuadrado y
normalmente veremos la lógica detrás de
esto vamos a resolverlo esto es igual a
raíz cuadrada 10 por 10 100 más 5 por 5
25 más 10 por 10 100 a su vez todo esto
es igual a 225 raíz cuadrada de 225 si
tuviéramos una cuarta dimensión aunque
es difícil de imaginar le agregaríamos
al cuadrado aquí adentro en la suma de
esta raíz cuadrada pero bueno en este
caso tenemos que hay que encontrar este
raíz de 225 y la raíz cuadrada de esto
es igual a 15 que es nuestra opción pero
veamos la lógica detrás de esto
calcular esta diagonal de aquí que les
estoy dibujando
de aquí acá
la podemos dibujar
si vamos a visualizar esto desde arriba
tenemos esta cara que estoy dibujando a
mano y quizás no me quede muy derechista
acabamos de dibujar esto esto es un
cuadrado porque mide 10 x 10 10 x 10
y queremos encontrar este valor lo
podemos encontrar porque este es un
triángulo rectángulo y para eso tenemos
el teorema de pitágoras lo que nos dice
que esta x va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada
de la suma del cuadrado de los catetos o
sea 10 al cuadrado más 10 al cuadrado
esto es igual a raíz de 200
ahora tenemos que visualizar lo
siguiente para calcular esta línea
diagonal que va de aquí a acá aún
tenemos un triángulo rectángulo pero es
un poquito más difícil de ver si yo
dibujo esta línea que acabamos de
calcular esta línea azul así que está
trabajando
diagonalmente la tapa de la caja tengo
esta línea de amarilla que es de 5
centímetros y tengo la línea verde que
me interesa que es la diagonal que
atraviesa toda la caja está verde de acá
que es esta pues igual aquí tengo un
triángulo rectángulo tengo este que es
mi ángulo recto y aquí tengo este raíz
de 200 que es lo que calculé hace un
momento raíz de 200 esta diagonal es
esta línea azul
esto ya vimos que vale 5 es la altura de
esta caja y tenemos que encontrar ésta
y esta que le voy a poner en verde igual
usando el teorema de pitágoras va a ser
que esta ya es igual a la raíz cuadrada
este cateto al cuadrado raíz de 200 al
cuadrado pues va a ser igual a 200
el cuadrado de este lado 5 x 5 25
que es igual a la raíz de 225 lo mismo
que obtuvimos hace un momento entonces
se va a aplicar esta raíz cuadrada este
principio de aquí que es la suma del
cuadrado de los lados involucrados en
esta diagonal y con eso terminamos el
vídeo de hoy nos vemos en el siguiente